foreign
well um good morning councilors
um I'd like to make a start if we could
please and um welcome to this standards
meeting it's the first of the new
Council I think it would just be helpful
if we were introduce ourselves I'm sure
we will know who each other are but if
we could go around
um I'm Louis bark I'm the chair of this
I've been um I'm a newly elected
councilor Town councilor and District
councilor and before that I was
a independent person of the standards
committee and I I was in that role for
about two years if we can then move to
advice chairman um councilor Hawkins
Institute yourself thank you very much
yeah councilor Carl Hawkins from the
beautiful Westward yeah
good to see you all thank you very much
councilor Ken James a member for
holdsworthy royal
s
thank you very much and welcome I should
have said I'm Westwood
okay and the officer's here today I
think we all know who who each other is
but if you want to say Who You Are
done Sandra Democratic Service Officer
foreign
governance and the monitoring officer
thank you excellent as we move on to the
agenda of items
first item on the agenda is apologies
for absence
okay one apology Mr Kenton Baker
thank you
you don't know where councilor
um Andrews is often heard
okay thank you item two the agenda was
the minutes of the standards committee
meeting held on the 16th of November
last year
um I don't I was present at that meeting
and Cohn I think um we're the only ones
who can vote on that
so can we have um a proposer yeah and
those in favor of
of that of those minutes
all agreed
abstain you weren't there councilor
James thank you
thank you next item on the agendas
Declarations of interest and I'm sure
people know what they are and you can
either declare any interest now or as we
go through the agenda
thank you
um item for the agreement of the agenda
between Parts one and two if applicable
and
have no part two we have no party yeah
thank you
item five urgent matters of information
to be brought forward with the
permission of the chair and the
committee any items I have none myself
there we are
good okay and we'll move on to item six
which is the introduction to the role of
the standards committee and we're going
to have a briefing
a brief briefing from head of Legal
Services
um Stacey Dory thank you Stacey
so John's you are a previous
Urban celebratory District returning so
I feel like I'm sort of preaching to the
the converted
um really
um just to say um I will introduce
standards and very briefly today and I
promise it will be briefly
and but we do have
um full standards training coming
forward
um so the next standards committee is on
the 15th of November so Beth Evans I
don't know if you've all met her before
I think most of you will have
um she's a really experienced
um practitioner on local government law
and standards so she will be at the next
standards committee putting some
training on
um and then we have
um two further sessions online
um one at 6 p.m on the 6th of September
and one at 2PM on the 19th of September
um so you don't need to attend both but
choose whichever day or time is suitable
for you and I say that one will be
online but I'd like to encourage all
members to attend so we can get the
message out there because I think that's
really really important
um I will obviously send a reminder out
to all members as well
um so we we do have a standards
committee you're here today
um that's a requirement well under the
localism ACT it's a requirement that we
have mechanisms to deal with complaints
that might come against councilors and
we do that by way of having a standards
committee
um uh that's how we've we've done it and
so
um the terms of reference are for the
members to promote high standards of
conduct
um to advise full Council on revisions
of the members code of conduct
um monitor the operation of the code of
conduct
Grant dispensations and should they be
needed for any members and deal with any
reports um that I submit in relation to
um complaints that are submitted against
councilors and I'm really pleased to say
that you know those complaints have been
quite few and far between
um you know we did have one last term
that's not secret we we publicize that
but in the whole um what we try and do
or what I do my best to do is try and
resolve them as informally as as
possible
and you know I keep that confidential
whilst that resolution is trying to go
through I mean they're usually ones that
are easily resolvable or of a
misunderstanding
um we do have a current
code of conduct that's based on the
Nolan principles
so selflessness
um so hold as a public office should act
solely in the terms of the public
interest
Integrity holders of public office must
avoid placing themselves under any
obligation to people or organization or
organizations that might try
inappropriately to influence them in
their work
they should not take decisions in order
to gain a financial or material benefit
for themselves and that's that's really
important and obviously members must
declare and resolve those interests
objectivity holders of public office
must act and take decisions impartially
fairly and on Merit using the best
evidence and without discrimination or
bias
accountability holders of public office
are accountable to the public for their
decisions
and actions and must submit themselves
to the scrotery necessary to ensure this
openness holders of public office should
act and take decisions in an open and
transparent manner so most of our
meetings
um are held in the public domain there
will be some circumstances where we go
into part two and that must remain
confidential and there's various reasons
why we'll go into part two
um usually if it's in relation to a
discussion about a private individual or
shows the financial business interests
of someone
um if we do go into part two you can
always ask the reason why and we'll be
happy to give that
openness holders of public office should
act and take decisions in an open
entrance I've just sorry just done that
in transparent manner honesty holders of
public office should be truthful and
Leadership holders of public office
should exhibit these principles and
their own behavior they should actively
promote and robustly support the
principles and be willing to challenge
poor Behavior wherever it occurs
um we do have a code of conduct and
that's published on our website I'm
happy obviously to give anyone a copy of
that
um one of the matters I was discussing
with the chair just before the meeting
is um
reviewing our code of conduct I think
it's um it's not out of date it still
complies with the Nolan principles but
the LGA a couple of years ago issued a
model code of conduct
um so I'd like standards to review that
with a view to
um making a recommendation or not
um for full Council to adopt that and
the reason I'm quite Keen to have the
model code of conduct is because the LGA
you're recommending that all local
authorities adopt that model one and
it's easier because then you've got
consistency across all all authorities
and we're not dealing with different
codes of conduct so that's something
maybe to discuss later on chair on the
forward plan
um the other items to review
um I would very much like to be reviewed
by the standards committee are our
hearing procedures
um and and and the process that we
um have take hearings to so that's
that's a another matter for review I
mean it's it's been quite a significant
time since they've been reviewed
properly
um
but I'm happy to take any questions like
I say I promised I wouldn't talk too
long today
any questions from anybody at all and
just my benefit really when I joined as
the independent person I kept looking at
those Nolan principles the seven
principles do you mind myself
thank you look at the code of conduct
from time to time as Stacy said it's
online I have a print copy at home and
decided to bet
um I think it's quite useful on the
hearing procedures yes particularly I
think that's an interesting one we need
to look at and I think in a way it's
it's a difficult one about sanctions
that unless we have any
particular changes from government on
that is was probably nothing more we can
do at the moment
something I was Keen to
look at and make any all members of the
standards committee aware of
are there no questions at all from
anybody about that
councilor Johns thank you
and you know the Nolan
principles uh you know it's good to be
reminded of that and of course it's
updated from time to time so it's good
to hear what Stacy had to say
thank you very much
councilor Hawkins
and when when we first talked about this
when I when I first became member a
counselor we talked about
when a counselor's got a problem if
they've been reported and it sort of
goes through a process you probably
received the complaint and it goes
through uh it tries to get dealt with
in-house
to begin with I think Martin has spoken
to people in the past
um it just always seemed a bit strange
to me that
the standards committee as a whole
in general doesn't hear anything at all
about those processes
it's almost like I realized we're going
to try and keep their information
private and it is personal and if it can
be dealt with in the background that's
great
um it's just that the hearing that we
had last year
is sort of from our point of view on the
standards we didn't hear anything at all
about it as such we may be Rumblings
here and there and then all of a sudden
they exploded into a hearing is there
any way we can get a bit of a
bit of a rundown or like a monthly
update as to just
the problems in general but not in
necessarily in detail yeah so
the reason it's kept confidential is
because we have many allegations against
you know different councilors and often
that's unfounded
um if if it gets brought to a committee
obviously our committees are public
hearings and I guess I'd put it to you
you know if if for example I had a
campaign against you that was completely
malicious or unfounded but I brought
that to a public meeting
um
it's not overly help helpful because
that's in the public domain from your
perspective so a lot of the complaints
are quite easy to
um to resolve from that that perspective
um the standards committee that we had
um last year or the standards hearing
that we had last year
um a lot of that that was kept in part
two and because there were um individual
complainants that we didn't want to put
into the public domain so we were
protecting their you know
um confidentiality But ultimately
um the sanctions were published and put
in the public domain and that was a you
know decision that standards committee
took I think on this occasion probably
quite rightly
um but that that's a reason usually that
we we keep them confidential to protect
the identity of of an individual and on
that specific one that you were talking
about there was quite a few individuals
um but it's interesting that you've said
about the independent person because
that that's a really crucial part of a
standards complaint so the independent
person is is totally separate to toridge
and we before we go forward to an actual
hearing they have to be consulted and
the member who the complaint is about is
entitled to consult that independent
um person to give that outside
objectivity to the situation and to
ensure kind of fairness within within
the process
if anything more you want to say at this
stage and does anybody else have any
suggestions ideas about what we should
put on the forward plan
okay
yes
obviously we've got the um training by
Beth Evans on the 15th of November and
so that will take up standards for that
for that day but um whether we could
have the review of the uh code of
conduct
in in September I don't know if you want
to put the review of the hearing
procedures on at that stage as well
I think that's an excellent idea even if
it's only brief it gives us an idea of
what what we have at the moment and what
we ought to be aiming for and what we
can add to make it better and fairer for
everybody so the with the new model code
it deals with um social media which is
obviously taking off more and more as
well so
um that that would be good to update
from that perspective but if you'd like
I can do a comparison between our
current code and the new model code and
then members can consider it side by
side and whether they want to make that
recommendation to adopt the the model
code
I think one of the things people ask me
about was sanctions and I know there's
probably very little we can do it at
this stage is there anything you can add
to that at this stage are things in the
move you know are they proposals from
central government that we
they will review sanctions and what and
we have available to local authorities
review works and they to remain as they
are I mean I whether
um you'd like maybe we do some
representations to central government in
respect of the
um
sanctions that we have available to us I
guess the major sanction is publication
um
and the removal from from certain
committees but I you know they are very
weak for for some behavior
um the only other thing coming through
um is we've had the sexual offenses
um legislation come through so if you've
been convicted of a sexual offense you
can't stand as a counselor and the other
one we've just had notification of is
harassment so if you've been convicted
of
um uh harassment offense and then again
that's going to buy you from standing as
a counselor so I think they are the
government is moving towards
um that I think I think
um
you know there's been some highly
publicized cases um in relation to
harassment and obviously serious
assaults against MPS and and councilors
so I think that that they're doing their
best but that's coming forward so I'll
update standards in relation to to that
but then that's not a sanction as such
that's just that's to Bar people from
standing as counselors in the first
instance which I think is is probably
right for those serious offenses
if you are convicted of those offenses
the sanctions we have are still the same
as they are now it may prevent you be
from becoming a counselor but while
you're acting as a council or being
elected there's nothing much we can do
they are and also it's up to members to
self-declare that so obviously we
ask members to undertake DBS checks
um and we offer that
um throughout the term and more
specifically when they first elected but
obviously not all members do um have
those checks so and this has been
discussed um historically
um when we reviewed the Constitution
um so it was decided by
um standards last time that if you'd had
your DBS check we would put on the
website that you'd been DBS checked and
if you hadn't we'd stay silent on it
because there were some members that you
know objecting to that
well I've just completed my DBS check
unfortunately I don't have any previous
records offenses so again you publish
that please
you will be published as DBS checked
thank you very much
good anything else at all advising from
that little discussion I think that was
quite useful
thank you very much and and we've
covered item seven forward plan
ideas about what we want on there
nothing else okay we move now to item
seven exclusions of the public
as I can see it there are no members of
the public present I have no part
teacher at all
um that's eight nine and item number ten
is complaint update and I think you've
probably that's under part two chairs
do you want me actually if we do go into
party Builders yes can we have a
proposal can we have a proposal then
please councilors are going to move into
part two thank you all in favor please
all in favor thank you very much